faire découvrir le cinéma aux plus
jeunes c'est le but du festival des
juniors qui fête cette année son 14e
anniversaire
parmi les enfants scolarisés dans les
écoles et collèges des mureaux de
verneuil-sur-seine vernouillet de meulan
et de gargenville seuls 10 ont décroché
leur billet pour cannes l'occasion pour
eux d'assister à des projections de
côtoyer les stars et de passer un peu de
bon temps sur la croisette
ils sont comme des stars sur la
croisette valentin marouane justin samia
fatimata camilla et jemima sont les
jurés du festival des juniors des
mureaux et côté cinéma ils sont presque
incollables la preuve quand on leur
demande qui est ingrid bergman l'actrice
dont le visage se trouve sur les
affiches du festival
c'est une actrice et une actrice qui a
joué dans des films dans les années
50-60 s'est mariée avec un un producteur
italien comme les stars les enfants du
festival des juniors sont invités à des
cocktails ce jour là ils ont rendez-vous
dans les jardins d'un grand hôtel
cannois pour un brunch organisé par la
région ile de france l'île de france sur
la côte d'azur
forcément c'est intrigant mais savoir
pourquoi avait marqué le des france
alors qu'on est à cannes
en fait c'est parce que ils ont ils ont
installé un stand pour montrer leur
action et heureusement agnès l'une des
accompagnatrices a réponse à tout de
france finance des projets cinéma sur le
territoire et puis il ya pas mal de
films qui sont tournés en ile-de-france
donc la région est partenaire de de
beaucoup de ces choses-là la région qui
est également partenaire du festival des
juniors un festival qui existe depuis 14
ans 14 ans qu à chaque édition des
enfants se voir récompensés de leurs
efforts par un voyage à cannes
c'est le point d'orgue on va dire de
tout ce qui s'est passé pendant l'année
puisque ils ont d'abord travaillé en
participant à un concours de critique et
ils ont été choisis donc ça veut dire
qu'ils ont bien travaillé
ensuite ils ont été mesurés du festival
des juniors en avril et ils ont choisi
un très beau film
le promeneur d'oiseaux comme grand prix
cette année et puis là on termine
l'année avec ce voyage à cannes et ils
ne sont pas au bout de leurs surprises
alors qu'ils attendent de jean paul
huchon président de la région ile de
france ils aperçoivent une autre
personnalité politique lui manuel valls
le premier ministre a fait bizarre
l'occasion est trop belle pas question
de le laisser partir sans immortaliser
cette rencontre imprévue
manuel valls encourage l'action du
festival des juniors et ses découvertes
du cinéma ça ne peut être que positif et
puis ils le font ici à cannes qui est le
lieu parfait pour vivre pleinement le
cinéma et comme le disait il ya la saint
jean paul huchon s'est sans doute l'art
où tout se mélange les émotions le sens
mais aussi la qualité et donc pour les
enfants je n'en doute pas un seul
instant c'est une belle expérience mais
nous font aussi vivre leur propre
expérience donc ça peut être utile à
tout le monde
une fois remis de leurs émotions il est
temps de repartir bientôt il faudra
retrouver les bancs de l'école
en attendant les enfants peuvent encore
savourer ces quelques heures sous le
soleil temime à vos magnifiques c'est
une artiste et pendant une semaine
jemima pu toucher du doigt son rêve
l'adolescente élève de sixième dans un
collège des mureaux se verrait bien
revenir un jour pour gravir cette fois
ci les marches du tapis rouge
pourquoi pas par moi depuis longtemps je
voulais être comédienne
oui comédienne et chanteuse donc ouais
ça me donne encore plus d'envié
quant aux autres ils se montrent plus
que satisfait comme samia 10 ans en cm2
aux mureaux on a vu la plage des stars
on a vu des grands building des
boutiques
on a fait des daevas la dent au maire on
a fait plein de valentin 11 ans en cm2 à
vernouillet a peut-être découvert son
futur métier photographe et j'ai pris
beaucoup de photos j on l'a vu inès de
la fressange après on a vu
laurence ferrari on a vu jean dujardin
bas après je vais le regarder
après bas après je vais je veux tu être
les imprimés pour donner quelques quêtes
jean autant de souvenirs qui resteront à
coup sûr gravé dans leur mémoire et dans
leur coeur